car
[音楽]
[笑い]
ブーブー1オーナーん
あああああん
某
[音楽]
アンバン
謎解きの館へようこそ
突然だが肇社長君をこの館に閉じ込めた
この館から脱出するためには館内に隠された
脱出に必要なカギを入手する必要がある
またこの館の中には4つの謎が用意されている
一つの像を解き明かすと鍵のありかに関する情報を一つ手に入れることができるぞ
全ての謎を解き明かし正しい情報を使うことでこんなや方から御坊脱出することが
出来れば君には1億円を与えよう
[音楽]
月やんけ
や欲しいけど
しかし君に残された時間はあと1時間な
1時間以内に脱出できなければこの館を爆発する
モス助けが必要ならこのいいヘアラビットに話しかけろ
ます僕今日んわ
終わった
神の何階は
占部
君がいいヘアーのビットカーン
ピンチがた助けてくれ
なるほど
きっとここから抜け出す良いパートナーになるだろう
俺は必ずこう館を抜け出し1億 mo
必ずて
ブーバーンね
いえまだあって書いてあるちょっとこれを大量に回収するパターンかこれは
はいいろんな吹けのした答えは
ンマってすごい情報量が多いのどの知ったにあるかそれだけを考えでなかなか大変かも
しれないが例えばやばい技でしたっ
はい
[音楽]
理想の今度なんかフレームが付いてるからする投げやすそうではありますね
なんだったん
多分全部集まったな
明らかにフレームがあるからちょっと合わせてくるだろうなこれまあこういう感じです
ね
[音楽]
ちょっと足りないないろんなつけどさを探すことでこばや日に使ったかな答えを見つけ
られてないから始め社長にヒントたそう
大変んはどこの人にあると書いてあったかなんてそんなにひねって考えても大丈夫だ土
の下にある粕漬け音が入った方が大変かもしれないがたやすくそこにある土保の慕っ
てると机のスターですよ
またか書く方が次 the 早速ちょっと仲間使って4日な
欲しいとこまできてるんでちょっとちんとございますいいえライター
he
こみ上げると s さんの養子になる
ザーッありがとうございます
わからんっ
コーナー濡れてましたねさっきラビット a 3てだからちょっとずらしたらやっぱり
ありました
答えはどこの人にあるためちゃった彼と復縁の下を探すでしょ
復縁した歌はや玉答え benito
tee
文章の中にもすっげぇがあるよ探しえみよ
だけやぞ
[音楽]
ブーブーブーブーおっしゃってるだからこの部分へほっ
ウォッチャー1うんショーパンドゥえっ
を言うムーティのシッターやん m いいよ
んんんヴァッハウンス計上してもよればいいんだ答えは鼻の中
ウィザーねこれ
[音楽]
イギー増小型になりました脱出するためのカギは高い所にあるよ
イージーてもらいましたあと3つのヒントがあるのでどんどん磨いていきましょう
一丁目から目指し新ともらったけどな
メディア
そこにはまた髪がありますた
オンラインに6人の人物が見えについて情報を話しているしかしこの6人のうち
タヌキが化けた偽物が3人混ざっている二世ものあずさば情報ついている希少なが
わかったら医者もの頭を上から読めてパンピちゃんが6つの家の中には動物がてみて
ちょち聞いたよ花さん6つの家の鹿でも住んでない家きやがったよ健太君のちゃん b
ちゃんは動物が住んでい
家は全部で二つあります超組んでをワールド2世右手後率いたぞ司くん最も多くいたが
便切った
ダイキくん同2時まで5種類いたよ3人が偽物短所しています
偽マダラ32音頭取りから嫁ということですねそして家があるんですよ盛りこれで情報
照らし合わせてやってるっぽい
6つのへ行きますいいんといいんセンター
年金ドライ4めちゃくちゃおりゃペンギン
そうキリン犬黄色いです犬
ピンクの z 武斗蔵入っいないこの像方をもとにこの6人のうちで誰か嘘言っていう
か調べると
ん
まず jins 数えましょうか
そうが2色
犬が4色ビンギンさん向きキリン1匹
第41匹この情報を基に嘘をついている人を割り出します
11 p 安全マン見ちゃうとついてますね塗っての家のうちどれも過ぎなきゃと言う
かなチャンは嘘をついてません
3匹以上の動物スティングレーは全部2つあります3匹以上の動物の違う1個
違う嘘ついて懸濁嘘ついてるね
最も多くいたのはピンギンターいいえいるです動物は全然分後所でいたよっ禁酒あって
いる上で終わる動物は全米腰聞いたよ
この人もう一ついてちゃんでしたじゃんっ
違うで5枚ペンギン3匹いるから重複円もウソをついていない
ていました嘘をついているのはバンビテンダー司この三人です今で嘘の3人を見つけた
のでその頭の上から4名とあっあっあっ
meet me てみたミーシャピアソラ3番ミッキーた司嘘ついてて上から読みます
パケットあった完全にありましたバケツです
ああいいいいペースじゃないか
はい影なり画像方にラッシュつするためのカギは椅子の下にあるよ
まだちょっと情報が足りないですね二問目はどうヒントです次の問題に行きましょう
結構時間に余裕がありそうだなバスできちゃうよ
sabon 概算です酒が置いてある場所に行き
くさんあるボールの中から神の中のもぞ見つけボールを叩いてを図りちょっと難しい
から移動しながら拝読しました
お酒あったねー
めちゃくちゃボールがつながっています鏡どねかから持ってる見つける
やばいスターてでいい
一旦すごい曲が出るそういう仕掛け
鏡の中からもちろんつけてどういうことがたくさんあるボールの中からって書いてある
から火山にも家があるということがわからんけどなんかそんな気がしますねキャビンに
チェストちゃんともちに見えるっていう鏡文字っていう反転して書いてあることがある
んですね
あではせで忘れませんでもさ逆に見えるでしょ
でもこれね鏡お越しに見ると時に見えるんですねこれかが意味もずですしたねこれ
[音楽]
ああああああ
なった
ハートですからてって目もあるんだよいっ
これじゃ人気は咳をしてきました
髪もず発見しました
さあ何が書いてあるんでしょ
はいぱー室するためのカギは2つの部屋のうち法人者にあるよ大事な品クラゲがします
んで
あと2枚
で外れてまだこれも外れながら3つの家トレックが当たりだったんですけど3つを
見つけちゃったんで速攻で林道全切りました
これで今私が持っている情報は足つするためのカギは高いところにあるらしくするため
のカギは伊勢の下にある腰出しするためのカギは2つの部屋のうち多い部屋にある3つ
の増派
ますもう一つのヒントでさん
大きな手がかりがつかめそうです4名いきましょう
これが4名かアーミングどぇーあの
音止めちょっと何なんだこれ分身ともなければ日っていうかけど1車
ちょっと待ってはここに来て難しいとフラミンゴの場所駅ウェバーと比較せよ足りない
ものがわかったらそれを探せ ember とあああっってほんとにょ情報量が多そう
よたほか中身もそうだったんですけど色すっ
が大きなしいただきますちょっと金持っています
30分経過でも半分だあと1問ですからこれを必ず得
[音楽]
ずれず色別に文字を開けてるんですけど今のところが家で意味わからん
通用せんじゃなんですけどこいつ紙集めてみますと話しちゃを全部
持って
wh
持っています
全部果たしたもののメンバー企画
あっ畑のメンバーだみんなでもこれ多分子まっとうなんですよしっ
あなた様ですこれとたなっちゃうんですねこれは洋平君
オレンジがとつばからプレ多分畑のメンバーですから俺じゃないとわからんぞ俺とう
いって並べてみます
[音楽]
[拍手]
ブーブー平成 pa だから多分セッティング入るパティ入る生プロスチーマーしっは
ええええええいいんっ ok
トマトくんの子なんですけど緑数えてみましょう5位
いいじゃん44つしかない突っ
をレンズも探したらこれ一本しかないってるこのオレンジ少ないからすぐないんだ
トマトくんの沸騰おおつ野つがない
普通です bar あるやんけ
ありましたと思うちもっち最後の1補助に脱出するための鍵の近くに果物が置いて歩い
をすべての人はそれました
もう1回増補整理しましょうか脱出するためのカギは高いところにあります
椅子の下にあります2つの部屋のうち ok になります
近くに果物が置いてあります
今月のヒントがある部屋を探しましょう
この館を取りてる都合上を吐きがありえるフェア2
こっちの小さな家大きな金とに待ったんですね大きいやぽっちな絶対この中で言う高い
ことにあるって情報からして持ちたの広いスペースにないんで間違いなく上ミアルって
いきましょう
ます
ちょっと9どうかにあるはず探しましょ
これじゃあ管をあるし難しいっ
あります国会難しいことがある
まっなにそれ
残念だからここには鍵はないようなもう一度限り館情報見直すと本当にすごい正しい
情報だったんだろう株処分で直径大
まってまっては誰もいません
待って
めっちゃロスするためのパティは一種のサティロス2つの部屋うち大きい家にあるよ私
せるための日青いて r 4 e 0そっこりゃーみなさんわかりますこれ
僕は分かりませんラベルとうーん
そつれその行ホをスーッたいった良い部屋
ラディは本本の脳いい部屋裏でだったかなぁあっ夫です
no コリッ10にゃ1にょろ透かしがミットっ
どうぞお家型そんなことじゃないのでなーんだ
ん
はぁ
しずれてしまいましたちょっと鬱ゲーな引きなどめっちゃ9 e ヘアーネットもいい
なんですよ
ここご覧くださいこれこういいでしょうこのもいいでしょう
ところがですよこれに今井っぽいんですこの2つの情報はどぅぞ
それを知ったには9小さい家の方にあるここじゃないっす月いきましょう
ああ jr
の部屋の高いところにあるして果物がある
[音楽]
あっは
パッカーン
えっさーか君つきましたこれ俺じゃないとことないよこれ
末次体ゲットしましたさあ
1億円
それにコケタンっ
[音楽]
山武
無事に4つの謎を解き明かして俺は館を出るためのカギを入手
あとはこの1億円はもう使えるだけ座
今回の謎解きゲーム俺の関税精舎
[音楽]
マッハ
ben はっはー
俺だったらこんな風だバー
あっ日ちょっと1
ああああああ夢かー
君は夢の中で僕を助けてくれた
村雲たーーーーよよく歌スンウで聞いたねありがとう
有名でから1億円はペンにファイラないんだ
&ねはいはいというわけで今回はこちらの en 8-4
ボスキャラクターのいいえヘアラビットですかわいいでそういうわけでみなさんご存知
でしょうか
いい部屋ネットさん賃貸仲介係数ががんばーわんでぃ
全国の賃貸情報から皆さんのご希望に沿った物件を佐和山な条件で探すことができます
って僕も結構引っ越したらするんですけどもやっぱりどんな物件がいいかどうかわかん
ないんで
今ニコいい部屋ネット
とさんとかで調べるマジ助かりますそして晴れが新生活が始まる方もう
たず始めた方がいいです経験ぞを簒奪が埋まってるんでも1月くらいからちょい仏教
調べたほうがいいかもしれません
gemini 今日1月18日なんですけど pa あの日らしいですそして動画を見
てね皆さんにはプレゼントキャンペーンがあります詳しくは動画のがような
を突っついてくださいみんなもいい部屋3ならいい部屋ネットで検索してみてください
じゃ
[音楽]
bl